en voyant les blessés soignés à
l'hôpital de nicolas yves aux mesures ce
que signifie se battre dans une ville
que les russes estiment stratégique
ces soldats ukrainiens sont des
miraculés à missiles de croisière s'est
abattu sur leur base à la lisière de la
ville
plusieurs hommes de l'art unités sont
morts d'autres sont portées disparues
quand le missile nous a touché le
bâtiment a commencé à s'effondrer depuis
le troisième étage moi j'étais au
deuxième et je me suis retrouvé au
premier coincé sous du béton et magenta
cassé mais ça va je vais me remettre la
virus allez vous faire [__] 160
soldats ont été admis à l'hôpital depuis
le début de l'offensive
ces deux derniers jours ce sont
majoritairement des civils comme cette
femme qui vit dans un village où les
russes ont réussi à prendre position
il y avait des tanks et des hélicoptères
et les soldats russes veulent manger
alors il centre dans les maisons pour
trouver de la nourriture
j'espère que des avions bombarderons ses
soldats pour ce qu'ils ont fait
conscient que les frappes vont
s'intensifier des habitants préfèrent
partir
les forces russes sont aux abords de la
ville de micola yves elles ne sont pas
entrées pour l'instant elle essaye de
pousser leur mouvement vers l'intérieur
de la ville ce qui leur permettrait de
couper la route entre dessin et kiev
pour l'instant les forces ukrainiennes
semblent tenir le terrain mais les
forces russes depuis deux jours
commencent à cibler les zones civiles
dans la ville de nicolet
dans ce quartier situé près d'une base
aérienne une roquette a touché cet
immeuble
ces jeunes ne comptent pas et va plus
pour août
tout le monde était choqué il y avait
des enfants on a été réveillés par une
première explosion qui a touché
l'immeuble et puis d'autres tout a
tremblé et le plâtre tombé du plafond
tout le monde panique et je vais rester
même si ça dure on peut rien y faire
les habitants le savent à micola yves
l'offensive russe ne fait que commencer